So here's the deal. Researchers recently tried to replicate a hundred experiments in psychology that were published. The Center for Open Science recruited colleagues from around the world to try and replicate them on the study. And found that most of them could not be reproduced with the same results. In fact, I'm... Welcome to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Today we're going to talk about what is being called a replication crisis in science. The replicators in this recent study fail to get the same findings from the original experiment. From cancer medicine to psychology, researchers are finding that many claims made in scientific studies
情况是这样的。研究人员最近尝试对已发表的一百项心理学实验进行重复验证。开放科学中心招募了世界各地的同行来尝试对这些研究进行重复。结果发现，其中大多数研究无法得出相同的结果。事实上，我是…… 欢迎收听《隐藏大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们要谈谈科学界所谓的“重复危机”。最近这项研究中的重复者未能从原始实验中得出相同的发现。从癌症医学到心理学，研究人员发现科学研究中提出的许多主张
fail to hold up when those studies are repeated by an independent group. Later in this episode, we're going to explore one provocative study that looked at stereotypes about Asians, women, and math tests and explain what happened when researchers try to reproduce the finding. We're going to use this story to explore a deeper question. What do scientists really mean when they talk about the truth? Let's take a moment to thank and share a message from our sponsor LearnVest. LearnVest is an online financial advice company focused on empowering people nationwide to make good decisions with their money. Studies show that writing down your goals makes you 49% more likely to achieve them.
当这些研究由独立小组重复时，往往经不起推敲。在本期节目的后面，我们将探讨一项引人注目的研究，该研究探讨了关于亚裔、女性和数学测试的刻板印象，并解释了当研究人员试图重现这一发现时发生了什么。我们将通过这个故事来探讨一个更深层次的问题。科学家在谈论真理时到底是什么意思？让我们花点时间感谢并分享赞助商 LearnVest 的致辞。LearnVest 是一家在线理财咨询公司，致力于帮助全国各地的人们就金钱做出明智的决定。研究表明，写下你的目标能让你实现目标的可能性提高 49%。
That's why when you work with LearnVest, you tell them what you want to accomplish, and they create a customized financial plan to help you get there. Plus, they pair you with a financial planner to help keep you on track. To see a sample plan and get a $50 credit, go to LearnVest.com slash brain. The crisis has actually been a long time coming.
这就是为什么当你与 LearnVest 合作时，你告诉他们你想实现什么，他们会为你量身定制一份财务计划，帮助你实现目标。此外，他们还会为你指派一名财务规划师，帮助你按部就班地达成目标。要查看示例计划并获得 50 美元的信用额度，请访问 LearnVest.com/brain。这场危机其实酝酿已久。
In 2011, for example, Dutch researchers claimed that broken sidewalks and courage racism. They published their findings in one of the most prestigious academic journals, Science Magazine. A couple of years later, another article in Science showed that when a gay person shows up at a stranger's door and speaks openly about what it's like to be gay, this has an extraordinary effect. It was the personal connection between the gay person who they were trying to show, you know, they're in person. People who are against gay marriage change their minds after these emotional encounters.
例如，在 2011 年，荷兰研究人员声称，破损的人行道会加剧种族主义。他们在最负盛名的学术期刊之一《科学》杂志上发表了他们的发现。几年后，《科学》杂志上的另一篇文章显示，当一个同性恋者出现在陌生人的门口，并公开谈论身为同性恋的感受时，会产生非同寻常的效果。这是同性恋者与他们试图展示的人之间的个人联系，你知道的，他们是当面交流的。反对同性恋婚姻的人在经历了这些情感碰撞后改变了主意。
It was the combination of, you know, contact with a minority coupled with a discussion of issues pertinent. The results were written up in the New York Times, the Wall Street Journal, the Washington Post. They were featured on public radio programs such as the Clip Your Hearing on Science Friday. Finally, in 2009, researchers claimed that by lingualism, the ability to speak more than one language is better for your brain. All these claims had serious problems. The Dutch claim was based on fabricated data.
这是你知道的与少数群体接触以及对相关问题进行讨论的结合体。《纽约时报》、《华尔街日报》、《华盛顿邮报》都报道了这些结果。它们还在公共广播节目中亮相，例如《科学星期五》的节目。最后，在 2009 年，研究人员声称，双语能力，即说一种以上语言的能力，对你的大脑更好。所有这些主张都存在严重的问题。荷兰人的主张是基于伪造的数据。
One author of the gay marriage claim asked for the paper to be withdrawn after concerns were raised about fraud. Both claims were retracted. Might be true? Might not. We don't know, because it turns out the researchers made up the data. The bilingual advantage paper wasn't fabricated, but it was missing important context. The researchers had conducted four experiments. Three failed to show that bilingualism was better for
同性恋婚姻主张的一位作者在人们对欺诈行为表示担忧后，要求撤回该论文。这两项主张都被撤回了。可能是真的？也可能不是。我们不知道，因为事实证明研究人员伪造了数据。双语优势论文并没有被伪造，但它缺少重要的背景。研究人员进行了四项实验。其中三项未能证明双语能力对
the brain. Only one experiment showed a benefit. It was the only one that was published. Angela DeBrown was on the team that worked on the bilingual Advantage study. It is troubling because we like to believe that what we see is actually it's truth. But if it's only half of the results we find and we're in fact hiding the other half of the results, then we will never really find out what's going on.
大脑更好。只有一项实验显示出了益处。这是唯一发表的实验。安吉拉·德布朗是参与“双语优势”研究团队的成员之一。这令人不安，因为我们愿意相信我们所看到的实际上就是真相。但如果我们发现的只是结果的一半，而事实上我们隐瞒了另一半结果，那么我们就永远不会真正弄清楚到底发生了什么。
At the University of Virginia, psychologist Brian Nosec decided something had to be done. Brian felt the problem was that too many researchers and too many scientific journals were focusing on publishing new and unusual findings. To a few was spending time cross-checking earlier work to make sure it was solid. One of the key factors of science is that a claim becomes a credible claim by being reproducible, that someone else can take the same approach, the same protocol, the same procedure, do it again themselves, and obtain a similar result.
在弗吉尼亚大学，心理学家布莱恩·诺塞克决定必须采取行动。布莱恩觉得问题在于，太多的研究人员和太多的科学期刊把焦点放在发表新的、不同寻常的发现上。很少有人花时间去交叉检查早期的工作以确保其扎实可靠。科学的关键要素之一是，一项主张要成为可信的主张，必须是可重复的，即其他人可以采取相同的方法、相同的协议、相同的程序，自己再做一遍，并获得类似的结果。
Brian launched an effort to reproduce dozens of studies in psychology. He published a report in 2015. We found that we were able to reproduce the original results in less than half of the cases across five different criteria of evaluating whether a replication was successful or not. Over the last year, there have been many debates about what this means. Some critics say it proves that most studies are worthless. At many universities, researchers feel it's their integrity, not just as scientific conclusions that are being called into question. At Harvard University, psychologists Dan Gilbert recently
布莱恩发起了一项努力，旨在重复数十项心理学研究。他在 2015 年发表了一份报告。我们发现在评估重复成功与否的五种不同标准中，我们在不到一半的案例中成功重现了原始结果。在过去的一年里，关于这意味着什么引发了许多争论。一些批评者说，这证明了大多数研究都毫无价值。在许多大学，研究人员觉得受到质疑的是他们的诚信，而不仅仅是科学结论。在哈佛大学，心理学家丹·吉尔伯特最近
published a paper calling Brian's conclusions into question. So I think we just have to use our heads to figure out which kinds of things we expect to replicate directly, in which kinds of things we would only expect a conceptual replication. And we need to calm down when we don't see direct replication and ask whether we really should have expected it all. To unpack all of this, let's take a detailed look at one study and what happened when researchers tried to replicate it. I think the story reveals many truths about the ongoing controversy. many truths about the ongoing controversy. When there were graduate students at Harvard, Todd Petinsky and his friend Margaret Shee often went to restaurants together.
发表了一篇论文，对布莱恩的结论提出了质疑。所以我想我们只需要动脑筋去弄清楚，哪种东西是我们期望能够直接重复的，哪种东西是我们只期望进行概念性复制的。当我们看不到直接重复时，我们需要冷静下来，问问自己我们是否真的应该预料到这一点。为了剖析所有这些，让我们详细看看一项研究以及当研究人员试图重复它时发生了什么。我认为这个故事揭示了关于这场持续争议的许多真相。关于这场持续争议的许多真相。当他们在哈佛读研究生时，托德·佩廷斯基和他的朋友玛格丽特·希经常一起去餐馆。
They went for the food, but they also spent a lot of time observing human behavior. We often, after class, would go to the cheesecake factory, and she would order strawberry shortcake. I would typically order a salad, and the number of times that the salad was delivered to her, and the strawberry shortcake was delivered to me. She also likes regular coke, and I'm a diabetic, so I drink Diet Coke, and without fail, the Diet Coke would go to her, and the regular coke would go to me. The waiters were stereotyping Todd and Margaret. The guy was probably ordering the less healthy stuff.
他们去是为了食物，但也花了很多时候观察人类行为. 我们经常在下课后去芝士蛋糕工厂，她会点草莓蛋糕。我通常会点沙拉，而且沙拉送到她面前、草莓蛋糕送到我面前的次数...她还喜欢普通可乐，而我有糖尿病，所以我喝健怡可乐，无一例外，健怡可乐会送到她那里，普通可乐会送到我这里。服务员对托德和玛格丽特进行了刻板印象。这个男生可能会点不太健康的东西。
The woman was ordering salads and diet drinks. Todd and Margaret knew there was lots of research into the effects of such stereotypes. Now getting a dish you have in order is one thing, but there are more serious consequences. Stereotypes can be hurtful, they can affect performance. But as Todd and Margaret observed the waiters, they realized something was missing in the research. The previous studies had focused on the negative consequences of stereotypes. Could stereotypes also work in a positive fashion?
这位女士点了沙拉和减肥饮料。托德和玛格丽特知道，关于这种刻板印象的影响有很多研究。现在，端上一道你点的菜是一回事，但还有更严重的后果。刻板印象可能具有伤害性，它们会影响表现。但当托德和玛格丽特观察服务员时，他们意识到研究中缺少了某些东西。先前的研究一直集中在刻板印象的负面影响上。刻板印象也能以积极的方式发挥作用吗？
We thought if we really want to understand how stereotypes operate in the world, we can't simply look at half of it. The young researchers brainstormed how they might study the other half of the equation. The answer came to them as they were, yeah, eating together. We were sitting in Harvard Square over ice cream and we said what we need is a group where the stereotypes go in very different directions. They wanted to study a situation where stereotypes could have both positive and negative effects. And Margotchy happens to be an Asian American and a woman and we were started talking about math identities
我们认为，如果我们真的想了解刻板印象在世界是如何运作的，我们就不能只看它的一半。年轻的研究人员头脑风暴着他们如何研究方程式的另一半。答案在他们一边吃冰淇淋一边出现。我们坐在哈佛广场吃冰淇淋时说，我们需要的是一个刻板印象走向截然不同方向的群体。他们想研究刻板印象既有正面影响又有负面影响的情况。而玛戈·希恰好是一位亚裔美国女性，我们开始讨论数学身份
and we kept going back and forth and back and forth and then literally at the same moment we said, well why don't we study Asian women and math? The experiment the design was ingenious and simple. There are negative stereotypes about women doing math and positive stereotypes about Asians and math. So what happens when you give a math test to women When you give a math test to women, who are Asian? We hypothesize that when you make different identities salient, you should expect different stereotypes to be applied. Todd and Margaret figure that if they reminded Asian women about their gender, they would
我们不断地来来回回，然后字面意义上在同一时刻我们说，嗯，为什么我们不研究亚裔女性和数学呢？实验设计巧妙而简单。女性做数学题存在负面刻板印象，而亚裔和数学存在正面刻板印象。那么，当把数学测试交给女性时会发生什么？当把数学测试交给身为亚裔的女性时会发生什么？我们假设，当你凸显不同的身份时，你应该期望应用不同的刻板印象。托德和玛格丽特认为，如果他们提醒亚裔女性注意她们的性别，她们就会
see the negative stereotype at work. But what would happen if they subtly reminded the volunteers about their Asian identity? The researchers recruited Asian women as volunteers and asked some of them to identify their gender on a form before taking a math test. Earlier research had shown that when you make gender salient in this way, this triggers the negative stereotype about women and math. Todd and Margaret reminded other volunteers, selected at random, about their Asian heritage. They wanted to make these volunteers remember the stereotype about Asians being good at math.
看到负面刻板印象在起作用。但是，如果他们巧妙地提醒志愿者注意她们的亚裔身份，会发生什么呢？研究人员招募了亚裔女性作为志愿者，并要求其中一些人在参加数学先前的研究表明，当你以这种方式凸显性别时，这会触发关于女性和数学的负面刻板印象。托德和玛格丽特提醒随机挑选的其他志愿者注意她们的亚裔传统。他们想让这些志愿者记住关于亚裔擅长数学的刻板印象。
After all the volunteers finished the tests, the researchers analyzed their performance. Todd was working down the hall from Margaret one day when he heard her call out to him. She just shouted, holy cow, it worked. So I just sort of ran down there and we started looking at the output together. The study found that when the volunteers were reminded that they were women, they did worse on the math test. When they were reminded that they were Asian, they did better. Same women, same math test.
在所有志愿者完成测试后，研究人员分析了她们的表现。有一天，托德在离玛格丽特不远的走廊里工作，听到她大声叫他。她只是大喊，天哪，成功了。所以我差不多跑了过去，我们开始一起看输出结果。研究发现，当志愿者被提醒她们是女性时，她们在数学测试中表现较差。当她们被提醒她们是亚裔时，她们表现得更好。同样的女性，同样的数学测试。
Negative stereotype, negative result. Positive stereotype, positive result. The study was an instant sensation. Psychologist Brian Nozek. This is one of my favorite effects in psychological science. Something that seems like it shouldn't be flexible, how well we perform in math, is flexible as a function of the identities that we have in mind and stereotypes associated with those identities. Asians being good at math, women being not as good at math. The study quickly became a staple of college textbooks. It says psychologist Carolyn Gibson. It is a pretty amazing finding and I thought about that study for the first time
负面刻板印象，负面结果。正面刻板印象，正面结果。这项研究立刻引起轰动。心理学家布莱恩·诺塞克。这是我最喜欢的心理学效应之一。看起来不应该灵活的事情，即我们在数学上的表现有多好，作为我们脑海中的身份以及与这些身份相关的刻板印象的函数，它是灵活的。亚裔擅长数学，女性不那么擅长数学。这项研究迅速成为大学教科书的主打内容。心理学家卡罗琳·吉布森说。这是一个相当惊人的发现，我读本科时第一次听说这项研究。
as an undergrad. It's been used as an example in social psychology courses for four years since it was published in 1999 and it's used as a good example for for stereotype threat and stereotype boost. But from a scientific perspective there was one big problem. It had never been replicated exactly. Somebody had never followed their their steps that they followed and replicated their results but it's been used to support further studies many times over the past 15 years. Brian Nosek agreed, someone needed to replicate the original study. He was pure heading a mammoth effort to reproduce dozens of studies in psychology.
自 1999 年发表以来，它已被用作社会心理学课程中的一个例子已有四年，并且它被用作刻板印象威胁和刻板印象提升的好例子。但从科学的角度来看，有一个大问题。它从未被精确重复过。从来没有人遵循他们遵循的步骤并重复他们的结果，但在过去 15 年里，它已被多次用于支持进一步的研究。布莱恩·诺塞克表示赞同，有人需要重复最初的研究。他正在牵头开展一项浩大的工作，以重现数十项心理学研究。
Along with a panel of reviewers, he selected this study for replication and asked Carolyn Gibson at Georgia Southern University to conduct it. Brian wanted the replication to closely match the conditions of the original study. If you don't do that, you're really conducting two different studies. After launching the replication, he had second thoughts about its location in the south. And the reviewers thought this looks like a case where the location might matter. Asians in the southern US might be a more distinct minority than Asians in the northeast or in the west. And so we recruited a second team to do a replication simultaneously at UC Berkeley in the West Coast University, where Asians are much more prominent members of the community. The team in Berkeley was headed by Alice Moon.
他与评审小组一起，选择了这项研究进行重复，并邀请佐治亚南方大学的卡罗琳·吉布森来开展这项研究。布莱恩希望重复研究能够密切配合原始研究的条件。如果你不这样做，你实际上是在进行两项不同的研究。在启动重复研究之后，他对它在南方的地点产生了二次想法。评审们认为，这看起来像是地点可能很重要的情况。美国南部的亚裔可能比东北部或西部的亚裔是更独特的少数群体。因此，我们招募了第二支团队，在西海岸大学加州大学伯克利分校同时进行重复研究，那里的亚裔是社区中更显著的成员。伯克利团队由爱丽丝·穆恩领导。
Alice was a fan of the original paper. When I heard about it, I just thought it was like one of the very cool demonstrations in social psychology. And so that's why I always liked this paper. She followed the protocol of the original Harvard experiment. She recruited Asian women, reminded them of the female side of their identity, or the Asian side of their identity, and then gave them a math test. So, what happened? When we compared just as the original paper did, when we compared the participants who were in
爱丽丝是最初那篇论文的粉丝。当我听说它时，我只是觉得它是社会心理学中最酷的演示之一。这就是为什么我一直喜欢这篇论文。她遵循了最初哈佛实验的方案。她招募了亚裔女性，提醒她们注意自己身份中女性的一面，或者亚裔的一面，然后给她们做数学测试。那么，发生了什么？当我们进行比较，就像最初的论文所做的那样，当我们比较处于亚裔身份凸显条件下的参与者与处于女性身份凸显条件下的参与者时
the Asian identity salient condition with the participants in the female identities salient condition, we found that there was no difference in their math performance. The celebrated study failed to be replicated. When Brian knows that he can announce the finding about this and dozens of other studies that could not be replicated, it caused an uproar. Newspaper articles called it a crisis. Critics called accusations about fraud and scientific misconduct. In a 6,000-word cover story, the conservative magazine Weekly Standard said that liberals
我们发现她们的数学表现在统计上没有差异。这项著名的研究未能被重复。当布莱恩·诺塞克宣布关于这项研究以及其他几十项无法重复的研究的发现时，引发了一片哗然。报纸文章称这是一场危机。批评者提出了关于欺诈和科学不端行为的指责。保守派杂志《标准周刊》在一篇 6000 字的封面报道中称，自由派
had been making up research into how stereotypes affect women and people of color. The Berkeley study however was not the only replication of Todd Petinsky in Margaret Shee's paper. Remember how Brian had two groups conduct applications? I asked Carolyn Gibson at Georgia Southern University what she found when she ran the experiment on Asian women and math. When primed with Asian identity, Asian females did better on a math test compared to those who had been primed with their female identity and then those primed with their female identity
一直在编造关于刻板印象如何影响女性和有色人种的研究。然而，伯克利的研究并不是对托德·佩廷斯基和玛格丽特·希的论文的唯一重复。还记得布莱恩有两组人进行重复吗？我问佐治亚南方大学的卡罗琳·吉布森，当她对亚裔女性和数学进行实验时，她发现了什么。当被灌输亚裔身份时，亚裔女性在数学测试中的表现要好于那些被灌输女性身份的人，然后那些被灌输女性身份的人
did significantly worse. Carolyn has no doubt about the meaning of what she found. I believe that it further supports the original finding and that it gives even more robust evidence to this idea, mostly because we followed the same method as the original study and because we collected more participants. And so we have a more powerful study. At Berkeley, Alice is unsure. I do believe that stereotypes in general do have effects on our lives.
表现明显更差。卡罗琳对她所发现的含义毫不怀疑。我相信这进一步支持了最初的发现，并为这个观点提供了更强有力的证据，主要是因为我们遵循了与最初研究相同的方法，并且因为我们收集了更多的参与者。因此，我们有一项更有力的研究。在伯克利，爱丽丝对此并不确定。我确实相信刻板印象总体上对我们的生活有影响。
But in terms of this particular finding about whether stereotypes can facilitate people's academic performance, I guess it has made me question whether or not that finding is true. Okay, so which is it? Should we trust the results of the Berkeley study and say that Todd Patenske and Margaret Shee's finding was disproved, or should we trust the Georgia study and say the finding was confirmed? What happens when scientific studies disagree with one another? The popular narrative of the replication crisis suggests that scientists are like dueling gladiators.
但就这一特定发现而言，即刻板印象是否能促进人们的学业表现，我想这让我怀疑这一发现是否真实。好吧，那么到底是哪个？我们应该相信伯克利研究的结果，并说托德·帕廷斯基和玛格丽特·希的发现被驳倒了，还是应该相信佐治亚的研究，并说这个发现得到了证实？当科学研究彼此不一致时会发生什么？关于重复危机的流行叙事表明，科学家就像决斗的角斗士。
If two scientists come up with different findings, it must mean one of them is wrong or worse, one of them must have faked her data. When we come back, we'll take a look at why this idea misunderstands how science is supposed to work. Our statistical techniques are probabilistic and not definitive. And so we absolutely need replications. But replications in our current academic climate are also serving the purpose of trying
如果两个科学家得出不同的发现，那一定意味着其中一个是错的，或者更糟糕的是，其中一个一定伪造了她的数据。当我们回来时，我们将看看为什么这个想法误解了科学应该如何运作。我们的统计技术是概率性的，而不是决定性的。因此我们绝对需要重复。但在我们当前的学术气候下，重复也服务于试图清除学术欺诈并作为检测技术的目标。这两者是重复研究的非常不同的使命。
to vet out academic fraud and are serving as a detection technique. And those two are very different missions for replications. Stay with us. Support for NPR comes from Eli Lilly and Company. For 140 years, Lilly has united caring with discovery to make life better for people around the world. Today, they're working to discover
请继续收听。NPR 的支持来自礼来公司。140 年来，礼来公司将关怀与探索结合在一起，让全世界人民的生活变得更好。今天，他们致力于在糖尿病、癌症、自身免疫性疾病和阿尔茨海默病等领域发现改变生命的药物。访问 lilyforbetter.com 了解礼来公司的人们如何将灵感转化为行动。支持也来自亚马逊原创剧集《高堡奇人》，该剧想象了一个盟军输掉第二次世界大战的世界，美国由纳粹德国和帝国主义日本统治。但秘密预言电影中的启示证明，我们的未来属于那些改变它的人。改编自菲利普·K·迪克的获奖小说，由雷德利·斯科特执行制片
a life-changing medicines in the areas of diabetes, cancer, autoimmune diseases, and Alzheimer's disease among others. Learn how the people of Lili turn inspiration into action at lilyforbetter.com. Support also comes from the Amazon original series, The Man in the High Castle, which imagines a world where the Allies lost World War II, and America is ruled by Nazi Germany and imperialist Japan. But revelations in secret prophetic films prove our future belongs to those who change it. Based on the award-winning book by Philip K. Dick, executive produced by Ridley Scott
并荣获两项艾美奖，现在就在 Amazon Prime Video 上流式传输新季。这是《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们来看看科学是如何运作的，以及社会科学中所谓的重复危机。当我听到有关这场争议的新闻报道时，我发现自己将它与我自己的职业进行了类比。新闻业。
and winner of two Emmy Awards, streamed the new season now on Amazon Prime Video. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're taking a look today at how science works and the so-called replication crisis in the social sciences. As I listen to the news reports about the controversy, I found myself drawing an analogy with my own profession. Journalism.
这就是我的意思。几年前，《纽约时报》的一名记者被抓到捏造故事。他没有前往各地采访人们，而是直接编造东西。报纸回过头来重新报道了杰森·布莱尔写的故事。当事实不符时，该记者被解雇了。想象一下，如果我们将《纽约时报》每位记者的每个故事都重新报道一遍，会发生什么。即使记者们做得非常完美，旧的新闻故事也可能不匹配。消息来源可能不会再次看到完全相同的事情。有时
Here's what I mean. A few years ago, a reporter for The New York Times was caught fabricating stories. Instead of traveling to various locations and interviewing people, he simply made stuff up. The newspaper went back and re-reported the story Jason Blair had written. When the facts didn't match, the reporter was fired. Imagine for a second what would happen if we re-reported every story by every reporter at the New York Times. Even when reporters are doing a perfectly good job, the older new stories might not match. A source might not see exactly the same thing again. Sometimes
如果情况发生了变化，消息来源可能会说完全不同的话。因此，当两个记者没有制作出相同的报道时，可能是其中一个人在编造东西。但更有可能是，他们两个都是对的。现在，我知道你在想什么。新闻是讲故事，科学是关于数据的。我知道你在想什么。新闻是讲故事，科学是关于数据的。但让我们仔细看看卡罗琳·吉布森和爱丽丝·穆恩对塔普蒂安斯基研究所做的重复研究中发生了什么。在最初的研究中，女性主持了实验。在佐治亚州，协调员也是女性。但在重复研究失败的伯克利，男性和女性协调员都主持了研究。这会产生影响吗？
if the circumstances have changed, a source might say something completely different. So when two reporters don't produce the same story, it could be that one of them is making stuff up. But much more likely, is that both of them are right. Now, I know what you're thinking. Journalism is storytelling, science is about data. I know what you're thinking. Journalism is storytelling, science is about data. But let's look closely at what happened in the replications that Carolyn Gibson and Alice Moon did of Tarpitansky study. In the original study, women administered the experiment. In Georgia, the facilitator was also female. But in Berkeley, where the replication failed, both male and female facilitators administered the study. Could that have made a difference?
让我们明确一点。所以这不是一次精确的重复。这里有一个例子。论文中清楚地提到，我不知道这个因素是否重要，一项研究中实验者的性别是男性，另一项研究中实验者的性别是女性。我不知道这是否是能够解释两项研究之间差异的因素。因此，让我们明确这一点，这不是一次精确的重复。这是宾夕法尼亚大学的埃里克·布拉德洛。
Let's be clear. So it was not an exact replication. So here's an example. It mentions clearly in the paper that, and I don't know whether this factor is important or not, that in one study, the experimenter gender were males, and another study, the experimenter gender were females. I have no idea whether that's a factor that could explain the difference between the two studies. And so, let's be clear about what, it's not an exact replication. This is Eric Bradlow from the University of Pennsylvania.
他完全有资格谈论这些事情。在沃顿商学院花了四年时间研究统计学和数学。后来获得了统计学博士学位。在过去的 20 年里，我一直在将统计方法应用于许多问题，但我认为自己是一名数学社会科学家。埃里克认为，要求研究实现统计重复，在得出任一结论为真之前或多或少要完美匹配，就像要求两个记者报道一场篮球比赛并带着几乎完全相同的报道回来一样。
He's eminently qualified to talk about this stuff. Spent four years here at Wharton studying statistics and mathematics. Went on to get my PhD in statistics. And for the last 20 years, I've been applying statistical methods to lots of problems, but I consider myself a mathematical social scientist. Eric believes that requiring studies to achieve statistical replication, to match more or less perfectly, before you conclude that either is true, is like requiring two reporters to cover a basketball game and come back with nearly identical stories.
精确重复是那种不存在的神话般的象牙塔的事情。我们真正需要思考的是，如果研究没有重复，为什么没有重复，即使它没有精确重复，它实际上也可能强化最初的发现。换句话说，你可能会更确信。这不仅适用于心理学研究。埃里克告诉我，NIH 的研究人员曾发现，给予镇静剂的实验小鼠需要 35 分钟才能恢复。当重复实验时，小鼠用了 16 分钟才恢复。科学家们抓耳挠腮，这毫无意义。
Exact replication is one of those mythological ivory tower things that doesn't exist. What we really need to think about is if the study doesn't replicate, why doesn't it replicate, and even if it doesn't replicate exactly, it may actually reinforce the original finding. In other words, you may be more certain. This isn't just true about studies and psychology. Eric told me that NIH researchers once found that lab mice, given a sedative, took 35 minutes to recover. When the experiment was repeated, the mice took 16 minutes to recover. The scientists scratched their heads, it made no sense.
花了一段时间才弄明白，本不应该产生影响的东西却产生了影响。在两次实验之间，动物笼子里的木屑被更换了。事实证明，红雪松和松木屑加快了镇静剂代谢的速度。桦木或枫木则不会。这并不是说重复实验是无用或毫无意义的。它非常宝贵。
It took a while to figure out that something that shouldn't have made a difference did. In between the two experiments, wood shavings in the animal cages were changed. Turns out that red cedar and pine shavings step up the speed at which the sedative was metabolized. Birch or maple don't. This is not to say that repeating experiments is useless or pointless. It's incredibly valuable.
但重复主要帮助我们理解围绕某种现象的细微差别。它们作为检测欺诈的工具并不是很有用。仅仅因为你得到不同的结果并不意味着你不应该信任它们。它们彼此的误差范围是多少？是否存在其他 variables 会使得在大学 A 完成的研究和在大学 B 完成的研究无法得出完全相同的结果？
But replications primarily help us understand the nuances around a phenomenon. They're not very useful as a tool to detect fraud. Just because you get different results doesn't mean you shouldn't trust them. How much are they with an margin of error of each other? Are there other variables that would make it so that study done at University A and the study done at University B wouldn't yield exactly the same thing?
我认为这是一种更好的看待方式，而不是说，如果你没有得到完全相同的结果，甚至是几乎相同的果，你就不能信任它们。我认为这是科学的表层水平。我认为你需要深入到那层之下，所以当你自己看到一项未被重复的研究，或者当你看到有时被称为失败的重复时，你的脑海深处难道不会说，嗯，这反驳了第一项研究吗？你真的从来没有那样想过吗？
I think that's a better way of looking at it than say, if you don't get exactly the same results or even results that are very nearly the same, you can't trust them. I think that's a superficial level of science. I think you need to go below that so when when you yourself look at a study that has not replicated or you looked at what sometimes called a failed replication do you not at the back of your mind say well this disproves the first study do you actually never think that way
呃……噢，什么，从来是个长词，从来不说从来不说从来是个强烈的词，你知道我在想，我得想想那部 007 电影，肖恩·康纳利说，我再也不会演詹姆斯·邦德了。然后 15 年后，他出了一部名为《永不说不》的电影。不，不，我永远不会那么说，但我要说的是：。假设你做了一项研究，你发现，你知道的，参加 SAT 预科课程的人在 SAT 考试中表现好 15%。
uh... oh what never's a long word never says never said never said strong word you know i'm thinking i have to think of that j Bond movie when Sean Connery said, I will never do James Bond again. And then 15 years later, he came out with a movie called Never Say Never Again. No, no, I would never say that, but I would say the following. Let's imagine that you do a study and that you find that, you know, people that take an SAT prep course do 15% better on the SAT.
再假设另一个人做了一项研究，答案只有 3%。现在，有两种可能性。一种是第一研究由于某种原因，高估了这种效应。这完全有可能。因此，3% 小于 15%。但请注意，如果你把这两项研究结合起来，你的发现可能
And let's imagine that someone else does a study and the answer's only 3%. Now, there's two possibilities. One is the first study for whatever reason, overestimated the effect. That's entirely possible. And therefore, 3% is less than 15%. But note, if you combine those two studies together, your finding might
实际上更强，在这个意义上，我现在更确信 SAT 预科有助于提高在 SAT 上的表现。现在，效应量可能会从 15% 缩小到 11%，但也要注意，我现在可能已经将样本量翻倍或翻了三倍，因此我的不确定性下降了，现在我甚至可能更确信 SAT 预科是有帮助的，也许不像在第一项研究中那样有帮助，但我仍然更确信它实际上是有效的。然而，当你想到科学的不同分支时，难道没有某些科学分支，你可以预期同一件事以高度可预测的方式一遍又一遍地发生吗？
actually be stronger in the sense I'm now more sure that SAT prep helps performance on the SAT. Now, the effect size may shrink from 15% to 11%, but also notice I've possibly now doubled or tripled my sample size, so my uncertainty goes down, and now I may even be more sure that SAT prep helps, maybe not to the degree that it helped in the first study, but still I'm more sure that it's actually effective. When you think about different branches of science, though, aren't there branches of science where you can expect the same thing to happen very predictably over and over again
当你观察粒子物理学时，例如，你会期望如果你从枪中发射，你知道的，两万个质子，它们基本上每次都会做差不多的事情。好吧，这已经，你在考验我对我在宾夕法尼亚大学上课时记忆的粒子物理学课的边界，但我的理解是，当然，这也是统计学家所研究的，对吧？我们研究随机性的概念。因此，每一门科学，每一门学科，除非你在谈论等号，比如 E 等于 MC 平方。
when you look at particle physics, for example, you would expect that if you fire, you know, 20,000 protons out of a gun, that they're basically going to do the same thing pretty much every time. Well, it's been all, you're testing the boundary of my memory of my particle physics class when I took it here at Penn, but my understanding is, of course, and this is what statistician study, right? We study the concept of randomness. And so every science, every discipline, unless you're talking about an equal sign, like E equals MC squared.
E 并不近似等于 MC 平方。它实际上是相等的。大多数物理定律和事情都不是等号。有近似号，所以这意味着其中存在随机性。我想如果你发射两万个质子，你会看到它们与其他粒子碰撞的方式存在偏差，并且存在随机性。
E doesn't approximately equal MC squared. It actually equals. Most physical laws and things aren't equal signs. There's approximate signs, and so that means there's randomness to it. I think if you fired 20,000 protons, you would see that there's a deviation in the way they collide with other particles and there's randomness.
我认为这在社会科学中也是如此。你引入 500 个受试者，你在大学 A 引入他们，你在大学 B 引入他们。人们的回答中存在随机性。当然，你希望总体模式是相似的，但这种认为你会得到完全相同的发现的信念，我不确定这是科学应该努力追求的东西。任何单独的研究都只是那样，一项单独的研究。它不是真理。
I think the same thing is true in the social sciences. You bring in 500 subjects, you bring them in at university A, you bring them in at university B. There's randomness in people's answers. Of course, you would hope the overall patterns would be similar, but the fact that this belief that you're gonna get exactly the same findings, I'm not sure that something science should be striving for. Any individual study is just that, an individual study. It isn't the truth.
每个观测都是一个点。它是一个圆点。我们观察圆点。然后我们观察更多的圆点。如果这些圆点能够重复，很好，那么我们就有了更多的信念。科学是关于知识的演变的，对吧？但这个过程永无止境。总会有更多的事情需要去发掘，更多的细微差别。我们对我们所知道的事情变得更加确定，我们也对所谓的边界条件或调节变量变得更加确定，例如。也许这种效应在城市地区成立，而在其他地方不成立。
Every observation is a point. It's a dot. And we observe dots. And then we observe more dots. And if those dots replicate, great, then we have more belief. Science is about the evolution of knowledge, right? But the process is never ending. There will always be more things to uncover, more nuances. We get more certain about what it is we know, and we also get more certain about what are called boundary conditions or moderators like, for example. Maybe this effect holds in urban areas versus not.
也许它在加利福尼亚成立，而在阿拉巴马不成立。也许它对持有这些刻板印象的人成立，而对不持有的人不成立。对我和说，这是科学的进步。我们发现了所谓的主效应，也就是，你知道的，刻板印象对结果有影响，或者启动对结果有影响。然后我们说，哦，顺便说一句，它在这些条件下不成立。这不是重复失败。
Maybe it holds in California and not in Alabama. Maybe it holds for people that are hold these stereotypes and maybe it doesn't hold for people that don't. That's, to me, that's an advance of science. We have found what's called a main effect, which is, you know, stereotypes have an effect on outcomes or priming has an effect on outcomes. And then we say, oh, and by the way, it doesn't hold in these conditions. That's not a failure to replicate.
这是对最初发现的更微妙的看法。在哈佛，丹·吉尔伯特说你可以期待一些研究每次都能几乎完美地重复，但在其他情况下，你正在研究的事物本身正在发生变化。因此精确重复是不可能的。心理学科学中有许多发现，我们预计几年后在不同的人群中能够非常精确地重复。眨眼条件反射就是一个很好的例子。如果我对着你的眼睛吹气足够多，当我抿起嘴唇时你就会开始眨眼。而且这在不同文化、不同时代、不同年龄组之间不会有太大差异。
That's a more nuanced view of the original finding. At Harvard, Dan Gilbert says you can expect some studies to replicate nearly perfectly every time, but in other cases, the very thing your studying is changing. So exact replications aren't possible. There are many findings in psychological science that we would expect to replicate quite exactly years later and on different populations. I-blink conditioning is a very nice example. If I blow in your eye enough, you're going to start blinking as I purse my lips. And that's not going to be very different across cultures, across times, across age groups.
其他种类的发现肯定会。社会心理学中我最喜欢的实验之一表明，当来自美国北部或南部的年轻男性受到侮辱时，他们的反应截然不同，因为北方人和南方人有非常不同的荣誉准则。现在你不能拿那个实验并期望在意大利做，或者期望在 25 年后做。这是一个属于它的时刻和它的时间的实验。我交谈过的每一位研究人员都告诉我，科学界内部有很大的共识。肯定有许多设计拙劣的科学研究。
Other kinds of findings certainly are. There's one of my favorite experiments in social psychology shows that when young men who are from the north or the south of the United States are insulted, they react very differently because northerners andoutherners have very different codes of honor. Now you can't take that experiment and expect to do it in Italy or expect to do it 25 years from now. It's an experiment that's of its moment and of its time. Every researcher I spoke with told me there's lots of agreement within the scientific community. There are certainly many scientific studies that are poorly designed.
有研究人员做粗制滥造的工作。大学和科学期刊面临着发表引人注目发现的巨大压力。但所有这些问题的解决方案，埃里克·布拉德洛、布莱恩·诺塞克和丹·吉尔伯特说，是更多更好的科学。埃里克·布拉德洛。真相会大白。会有更多的圆点出现。会有更多的圆点出现。如果事实证明我发表的东西，不是因为我做了什么欺诈行为，只是因为样本量或我收集数据的方式而并非真实，那么你知道吗？科学最终会弄清楚我所说的是不真实的。所以如果你想要一个更……
There are researchers who do shoddy work. There is great pressure at universities and scientific journals to publish striking findings. But the solution to all these problems, say Eric Bradlow, Brian Nosek and Dan Gilbert, is more and better science. Eric Bradlow. The truth will come out. More dots will come out. More dots will come out. And if it turns out that what I published, it's not because I did anything fraudulent, just isn't true because of sample size the
布莱恩·诺塞克对他的关于可重复性的发现被误解为未能重现的研究毫无价值感到困惑。他启动了一个新系统，在这个系统中，研究人员注册他们研究的方案并承诺坚持到底。科学期刊承诺发表这些研究的发现，无论结果是否具有吸引力。
way I collected the data, then you know what? Science will eventually figure out that what I'm saying is not true. So if you'd like a more... Brian Nosek is bemused that his findings about replicability have been taken to mean that the studies that fail to reproduce are worthless. He started a new system where researchers register protocols for their studies and commit to sticking to them. Scientific journals commit to publishing the findings of these studies, regardless of whether the results are sexy.
科学是积累证据的缓慢进行，人们很容易想要一个简单的答案，它是真的吗？人们很容易想要一个简单的答案。它是真的吗？它是假的吗？但实际上，重复只是一种积累更多证据的机会，以便对该特定效应获得更精确的估计。对大多数人来说，关于科学真理的辩论是一个抽象的问题。我们大多数人向科学家寻求答案。我晚上应该喝一杯红酒吗？这种药给生病的母亲吃安全吗？
Science is the slow march of accumulating evidence, and it's very easy to want a simple answer, is it true, and it's very easy to want a simple answer. Is it true? Is it false? But really, replication is just an opportunity to accumulate more evidence to get a more precise estimate of that particular effect. To most people, the debate over scientific truth is an abstract issue. Most of us turn to scientists for answers. Should I drink a glass of red wine in the evening? Is this drug safe to give to my ailing mother?
每当我的孩子做了一件很酷的事情时，我都应该给她一美元吗？实际上，科学更多地从事提出问题的业务，而不是回答问题的业务。几乎每一篇科学论文都以呼吁进行更多研究告终，这是有原因的。特别是在涉及人类行为时，关于人类几乎可以得出的每一个结论都有大量的例外。人们是自私的吗？
Should I give my kid a dollar every time she does something while it's cool? In reality, science is more in the question business than the answer business. There's a reason nearly every scientific paper ends with a call for more research. Especially when it comes to human behavior, nearly every conclusion you can draw about human beings has tons of exceptions. Are people selfish?
是的，除了每天有数百万人表现出利他行为。人类是善良的吗？是的，除了极少数物种能够展现出更大的残忍。如果你想要永远不变的答案、确凿的结论和终极的真理，大概率，你不需要问科学家。本期《隐藏大脑》由卡拉·穆克-艾利森、马克斯·内斯特拉克和玛吉·彭曼制作。我们的员工包括蕾妮·克拉尔、珍妮·施密特以及我们的监督制作人塔拉·博伊尔。我们本周的无名英雄是卡米尔·斯迈利，她真正做到了人如其名。卡米尔
Yeah, except millions act altruistically every day. Are humans kind? Yes, except that few species are capable of greater cruelty. If you want answers that never change, definitive conclusions and final truths, odds are, you don't want to ask a scientist. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Karamurk-Allison, Max Nestrak and Maggie Penman. Our staff includes Renee Clar, Jenny Schmidt, and our supervising producer Tara Boyle. Our unsung hero this week is Camille Smiley, who truly lives up to her name. Camille
是我们部门的行政助理，也是我们最喜欢的人之一。无论你是想碰撞想法、订购办公用品，还是只是在她办公桌旁磨洋工，卡米尔总是乐意帮忙。想要了解更多《隐藏大脑》，你可以在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上找到我们，并在当地公共广播电台收听我的故事。说到你当地的公共广播电台，现在是奉献的季节。如果你喜欢这个节目，请考虑支持你当地的电台，并告诉他们是《隐藏大脑》介绍你来的。
is the executive assistant for our department and one of our favorite people. Whether you want to bounce around ideas, order office supplies, or just procrastinate next to her desk, Camille is always game to help out. For more Hidden Brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. And speaking of your local public radio station, this is the season for giving. If you enjoy this program, please consider supporting your local station and tell them hidden brain sent you.
只需几分钟，并且可以税前扣除。前往 stations.npr.org。谢谢。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是 NPR。当你回顾过去一年时，你可以回听。新的 NPR 播客和老牌最爱都在 NPR One 应用程序上等着你。重新潜入并收听 Embedded、Invisibility、Code Switch 甚至是《隐藏大脑》的档案。它非常适合长途旅行或在假期派对中抽空收听。
It'll take just a few minutes and it stacks deductible. Go to stations.npr.org. And thanks. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. As you look back on the past year, you can listen back to. New NPR podcasts and old favorites are all waiting for you on the NPR One app. Dive back in and listen to embedded, invisibility, code switch, or even the hidden brain archive. It's perfect for a long road trip or a break from the holiday parties.
随时在 NPR One 应用程序上或访问 npr.org/podcast 收听。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Listen anytime on the NPR One app or at npr.org slash podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随时可以通过 NPR One 应用程序或访问 npr.org/podcast 收听。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。